Here. Well tangible has a way of
screening people i guess you'd say
and that is that anybody
that wants to move on to
that community has to meet the tribe and.
And it's got briefly who they
are and what they're on about.
And then it's up to the
tribe and the hamlet
that you're actually moving on to so
when i moved onto the hamlet of pala.
I had to meet all the
neighbors and talk with them.
It was a safety mechanism for me
because i could soon start out
that i wasn't living next door
to a home with a shotgun. And.
They could soon start out
that i was a peace loving hippie type
too so it was a great safety valve
and then for buying a house there.
It's a matter of having to rent
there first for 12 months.
And i think i feel that's really good
and i'm sure that's why the
families are so contented
and i don't have to carry a great
deal of defence around with them.
My house powers like i think 98 percent of
the houses on tangible it doesn't have a
lock and.
I've never had any trouble with people using
the house if you're walking by people
might use you dani.
But they're certainly not in your
living room or having cups of tea
or stealing things i've had no
trouble with they're my motorbike
that they're my house.
They're quite unlike what.
Well yeah. Most of the houses
the set back into a rainforest
and so they're very private and although
our neighbours are quite close.
We can't actually see them if
i was to yell off my veranda.
They might hear me and i can certainly
hear one of my neighbours being often
and playing the guitar. Fortunately has
a good voice and plays guitar. Well.
But yeah it's rainforest it it becomes
quite leeches in the wet season
and we have about eight or 12
weeks of that each year and.
So they can get a bit muddy
underfoot rain boots country
but for the rest of the years.
Very beautiful and we have many
trees from all over the world
and coffee's ground there. And so and.
Lots of exotic plants
that you don't see in many places
other than the potential garden and.
And it is this love for the earth
that people have brought back things
from other countries and grown up there
and it's fantastic.
For. Less.
So yes we have a tribal council which
is very similar to any council
that looks after a body of
people and the tribe insists
that there's no real profit
making on real estate there. So.
The house that i'm in has a set price and.
The owner couldn't put upon herself
that it was worth twenty thousand more
because neighbors neighbours houses there
were twenty thousand more. It hasn't
gone up with the rest of inflation.
And so the average house there would be
about twenty ten to twenty thousand dollars
which is very realistic in this neighborhood
because if you're looking at a few
acres on your own with a comfortable dwelling
you might be looking at seventy four.
He's thousand dollars makes it very
realistic for young parents to move on
and to want to start having
children because they haven't got
that huge mortgage to have
to worry about or attend to.
And it means to a lot more
time spent with the children
and i think that's why the kids are walking
around quite contented they do see a
lot of dad and they do see a lot of.
And it's grace.
Oh yes there's a share.
It's a share system and to buy shares
intangible a share cost $500 deal.
And i'm sure that's been a
stable price now for 10.
10 years or 15 years
or even the whole existence of it has most
probably been something very realistic
like
that.
You know.
Places.
People.
My views on poverty.
But happiness and joy
and i see a lot of happiness there and
no i don't see a lot of new commodores
or shiny lawnmowers that you see it on
and i get values are looked upon slightly
different than how they may be looked
upon in it's easy where the
news is certainly a value on
tangible. I guess we'll fortunate
to have two or four wheels
that are still managing to get across the
road to get the kids after high school
or to get around to do the shopping. But
the community self is actually very good.
It had its own bus service its own bus
shelter and that's set up for people that.
Haven't got cars for the single mum
that don't have cars for the kids
that just want to go to
nimbin and play on opinion
or whatever they consider the bus
shelter and as as a driver myself
when i drive past the bus shelter never
sitting there like a cab rank whoever was
there for the first one on my motorbike
riff i have room for three in my car.
It can fit the first three in and
i've never seen people drive past me
when i want to go to town.
If it's pouring rain.
I don't want to sit on my motorbike.
I said in the bus shelter and the first
car that goes past will be the car
that picks me up and i
really like that aspect
and likewise for the return journey from
nimbin out to tangible isn't a problem for
lift all the time.
Yeah. On top of all people
do share their food
and there's a lot of food grown
there and there's massive orchards
that aren't there to make
massive sums of money.
They're there for people to pick
the mandarins or the peaches
when they're riding past on their horse
or walking past on port and i like
that idea and.
I don't think i've ever left a neighbour
without holding on to the kini a potato
or something and it's
usually a little bag of.
You know vegetables which is fantastic.
Oh yes i guess my favorite story
for tons of all would be is oh ok.
Yeah one of the. The best times for me.
Tangible was when i took my mother
out there with my niece and nephew.
And they spent the day there and
we walked all over the commune
and saw most probably 100.
Houses and teepees and dwellings where
people live and when will evening.
Dawn who is quite middle class and
quite sydney said to my niece
and nephew i bet you didn't expect
when we drove into this valley to
meet so many interesting people
and to see so many
beautiful dwellings and.
I think that was a
wonderful story because.
Dawn had never seen anything like that
before and she fell in love with it
and i thought that was very very good
because there is no curbing gathering
and there are no electricity power
poles running along and that.
One can feel alienated without things i
guess after living with them to 60 years.
Steph i don't feel very
comfortable there immediately
and to get the vibe of the place immediately
i thought was a wonderful thing.
Why.
Goddy eccentricity.
I hate to call those people that. I think.
Most people see themselves as doing what
they want to do one of their childhood
dreams one of their adult dreams
they can out leave it there
and it's not a great cause like
the dream about 100 foot yacht
or the mansion on the hill can often be
very frustrating dream because you spend a
lifetime trying to get to that and
it tangible it's more realistic.
So people can out.
They can live their dream they
can bring their children up
or in my case they can walk around feeling
very comfortable being who i am. And.
I think that's good to have such
a neighborhood on the planet.
Yet i think that. All intangible do
you have a very high level of talent
and it's great.
I'm sure that yeah
when people go outside the
guidelines if they if they're not.
If they're having problems
within their domestic life
or within their neighbor life. It's
very common. I think on the outside.
To just call the police
or to call an inspector
or to get the outside to actually pay
and to work out the decision making.
I find it tangible a lot of it's
kept within and worked out within
and other only thing think
that story through it
and yes it must be very frustrating.
While those people are
in such a dilemma and
that they certainly have the
time to persevere with it
and give it the time to persevere
and. Yeah i've seen it work.
It's good and. Thank you.
So people you know.
Do more.
It's actually mark but even calls
me marcus. Doesn't really worry me.
Probably not.
Ok. Right now.
Mark jackson
and i moved to nimbin just because it seemed
like a nice thing to do for a weekend
at the time and there was rides
available with the supplies truck
that was bringing supplies down to the
crew who were making the preparations for
the festival and.
So about two
and a half months before the first
of all i came down for the weekend
and 20 years down the
track. I'm still here.
And it was really just a nice
thing to do for a weekend
and you know nice trip to the countryside
and i guess i just fell in love with
the environment around an indian
and we used to come down the back
roads through the no valley so
that even on the trip down you know it
was like going through primeval jungle
compared to what i was used to you know
brisbane being a bit of a concrete jungle.
So i was a complete contrast
and i think it was really a matter of
falling in love with the environment really
that made me enjoy coming
and cause me to stay.
Well i think i was probably found.
You know 10 or 15 years before
that the term was thought of.
Living a fairly decadent lifestyle and i
think it had a lot to do with the fact
that i saw
that i was living in an intensely decadent
civilisation whose means of production
was sort of based on it
on its own demise and.
Yeah i think the concept is no
future which was the concept
that the punk generation's sort of
brought to light was you know a strong
perception in my life at the
time so you know basically.
Working in a mental
hospital and drinking a lot
and doing various other
bad things to my body
and moving to nimbin was just like getting
back in contact with life you know sort
of being connected with nature looking
at how useless i was probably the key
realisation that i'd been trying
to be someone who sits at a desk
or does something similar
to that and had no life.
Skills whatever in terms of
you know cooking building.
You know doing anything
that was immediately useful
in the survival sense.
Well it wasn't really the
aquarius festival as such
and in fact by the time of the equerries
first of all which is about three months
after i arrived in nimbin i didn't bother
to go to the first of all because you
know by then i was living in
a farmhouse outside of town
and was so sort of in love
with survivor lifestyles
and the back to nature movement that.
About that we couldn't be bothered
going into town to celebrate
that you know i was just quietly
celebrating via my self.
The fact
that i was living in the countryside.
It was really a process of becoming
involved in all of the processes
that make life possible
and trying to get involved with
them in a you know holistic way so
that you know recognising
that i needed to eat.
I became involved in growing vegetables
in varying cairns in cooking
and you know that whole process.
And you know applying that
that sort of holistic involvement with those
processes across all areas of my life
and probably in particular becoming
involved in the tree cycle.
If you like and you know
that the first contact being wanting
to make a musical instrument.
A guy that i knew and this is
probably six months after the first
or so i was making dulcimers which were
forced to being a musical instrument from
the appellation mountains making one
obviously involve getting some woodworking
tools and among the woodworking tools but
that i either border was
given was a chainsaw
that i was given by the guy
called sam at. By who.
And the sawmill at the end of all fours
co-operative property before it was the
carnival co-op.
He gave me a chainsaw and i was
building a house by this time
and the guy who'd cleared a building
site with his bulldozer offered me a job
logging and because i was
building a timber house
and various other reasons i thought
that it was probably the fair thing
to take the logging job so i did
that you know worked in the timber
industry for about two years and.
Having been involved in cutting
a lot of trees down i thought
that i should plant sun.
So what would have suited me at the
time was to work for the government.
You know would rates of pay part time
and get a bit more than the dole
and have the rest of the time free
but because there was nothing
happening along those lines.
I started a reforestation contracting
business by advertising through the local
newspapers and found
that there was a very substantial demand
from people who wanted trees planted on
their land. So you know we
planted 85000 trees for.
Say you know 100 different landowners
over the next five years and till
that business was cleaned up in
the recession you ninety three.
At which time i had a bad back chronic
tin ear and about $5000 worth of debts
and went up to brisbane
and worked in a bar for a couple of
years to get myself back on my feet.
Building the house was quite an experience
because we did it in 1974 which was the
year of you know the biggest flood
that we've had in in recent times
and so it rained. Fairly solidly
for about five months but.
It was a great experience.
You know sort of picking up
building skills as you go along.
Using the materials
that came to hand like the whole house
cost of the order of a thousand dollars to
get. You know the basic
house structure up so
that for example the uprights in the house
were split out of dead trees on the
property
and then brought axton ads to you know
provide a sort of five by five for a few
beam and you know lots of second
hand materials recycle materials
and they turned out quite
a beautiful structure
and well while we didn't have any of our
kids at home at it it's good for about i
think 15 years and had
one child born in it.
Lasted well and you know
gave a lot of people shelter
and satisfaction at an event.
I think nimbin was the focus for
all sorts of alternative ideas
and a lot of those ideas have now been
co-opted into mainstream society you know
the you know 15 20 years ago. If
you are brown rice and so on.
You're some kind of fruitcake
and now you could be the prime
minister a lot of the ideas
that were looked on as
you know sort of wild
and fanciful then as i said now mainstream
and environmental concern certainly
in that category of ideas
that were espoused strongly there
that are now the concern of everyone.
So i think
that as a focus for alternative ideas it
certainly played a substantial role in the
environment movement.
Also there's been a lot of major gains
in terms of forest issues made not
necessarily by people at nimbin but
by people who are you know among.
The alternative lifestyle
community on the north coast
and probably notably the
community at rainier creek.
The cessation of rainforest logging in
new south wales was largely a result of
that protest
and the subsequent protest at mount nardi
against logging in the nightcap national
what's now the nightcap
national park up there
and i was actually arrested there on the
the day before the the decision was taken
to stop rainforest logging in
new south wales or a decision
that purported to stop rainforest logging
in new south wales was taken the day
after that.
Probably the one thing that needs to be
said is that they were a great party.
You know i think everyone who came to the
protest while there was a lot of grief
about what was happening in the forests
there was a lot of joy in coming together
and working for a common cause.
And certainly very positive experience i
think for everyone who are attended the
protest including probably
some of the police and
and maybe even some of the
loggers you know i think
that perhaps even they weren't a bit
but yeah it was great things going on.
You know sweat lodges and you
know campfires and lots of music
and months of massages
and you know there was a strong festival
element to all of the forest protests
that i've seen.
I think so. Certainly concern
about the environment is a theme
that runs through all of alternative
ideas and you know the idea
that we're basically part
of nature and need to.
Moderated my to moderate our
demands on natural systems
and live in harmony with nature is you
know one of the key concepts in the whole
alternative movement that
answers your question.
Oh
yeah well there's a
reorientation of priorities
that comes from moving from
the city to the country
and the idea of becoming more
involved in the processes
that make your life possible.
I think you know involves a
fundamental shift in values.
Having said that there i mean just
by coming to value natural processes
and trying to become involved in natural
processes in a holistic way doesn't mean
that you suddenly cut yourself off
from your past and people often expect
that people are moved to the country
necessarily stop all the habits
that they had when they were
living in the city and that
that certainly isn't the case.
So it's been a dialectic
you know between hope
and despair i suppose you know
despair being the paradigm
that it's dominant in you know
sort of poor urban lifestyle
and it's a fair bit of despair in a
poor rural lifestyle i'd say too
but at least once you know in intimate
contact with nature and the forces of life.
So that i think i spent a
lot of time between then
and now sort of poised
between hope and despair.
I mean there's still a lot
of strong indications
that the human race is
down the tubes in in.
Next a century
or two you know in terms of quiet matic
disruption the greenhouse effect the ozone
layer the place
and all of those sorts of problems if they're
not addressed are obviously not very
favorable to the survival of our
species. And i think that it's.
Very important
that alternatives to you know the current
consumer oriented lifestyles are put
forward
and i think you know that's part
of the real value of an inventive.
Well i think you know there was a
reasonable component of i've had an ism.
Although i mean how much of the activity
that passes beheading is an
actually creates pleasure.
You know in the short medium or
long term is probably questionable
but you know i think a lot of what
some people would see as head in is
and hurts a lot you know
and a lot of what passes for hidden ism
is really about escaping from painful
realities.
And those realities if you try to escape
from the intended just become more painful
and other major change in since
i want to show those windows
that are going to be a problem with.
A major change in number
that i've seen since 1973
and actually occurred you know
fairly definite time about three
or four years after the first of all was
the arrival of smack in then you know
prior to
that there was virtually no street crime
you leave your keys in the uk have no
concerns about the security
of your home and so on and.
You know as soon as hard
drugs arrived in the bin
or you know visibly arrived in them.
When that all changed
and you know on a certain level of places
been going downhill since then you know
in terms of social amenity
and so on and i think
that that's probably a faction of that
polarity between hope and despair.
You know
that there's a cause for great hope you
know given some of the alternative ideas
that have come forward and there are
drops in by mainstream society.
There's also considerable
grounds for despair
and individuals you know caught between
those two poles can go either way
and i think
that women is a place where both extremes
are highly visible you know where you've
got some of the most constructive alternatives
in terms of you know environmental
work in terms of alternative technologies.
You've also got substantial number of
people who live there who are basically
concerned with wiping themselves out
and nimbin seems to be a place of
extremes you know one of the things
that i used to say about an indian is
that it was a very tolerant place in fact
it was the town where even intolerance
was tolerated
and yeah it's certainly a
place a visible extremes.
Of a number of different spectrums.
There was a few reasons
why i left nimbin one was
that i wanted to study at university
and you know get more actual
skills in environmental management
and so i was much more convenient.
Given that the university was in
lismore to move into this more
but also an immense
quite a small community
and it can be quite difficult living in
a small community in terms of everyone
knows what everyone else
is doing all the time
and you know you need certain amount of
anonymity is always quite good to have in
your life.
So being part of a larger community is as
as i mean lose more as is another of the
reasons why i left there.
I think the main thing
that puts strains on relationships
at an indian is the fact
that there's very little work and
consequently very little income
and so you know building a
house and raising children
when you're on the dole is
basically extremely difficult
and you know maintaining a relationship
in those extremely difficult economic
circumstances is is not
an easy task. So that.
While i was doing the tree planning
business i was probably earning less than i
would have been getting on the dole.
So yeah just that many years
of that level of poverty.
I think that places great
strains on relationships
and certainly did online.
No favorite moments story.
Couple of favorite no names cinna no
time firmly in cheek i mean the places.
Been extremely important in australian
society i do remember graeme dunstan saying
to me once that in 1938 39 the place
a very young man of good will.
Was inspired and on in 73 it was
in then i'd still tend to believe
that there is truth in that.
And that as a focus for alternative ideas
that an immense played a very
important role in australian society.
I think like the rest of australia.
Nimbin has made significant gains in
terms of the natural environment through
reestablishing tree cover and so on.
But in terms of whether it's done
enough i'd say definitely no and that.
You know the newman valley is probably
one of the best areas in australia for
growing trees
and while there's significant numbers
being planted i think we need to get made
workforce and commercially driven tree
growing activities and. And we also need.
An acceptance across a society that
the environmental cost of the vellum
and always need to be balanced by environmental
benefits to counterbalance those
costs.
I think it's not just a challenge for new
minutes the challenge for us to alia to
realise that we are the get sustainable
or we're on the way out.
Limit is always been a magnet for fruitcakes
of various kinds you know other people
who. You know because their
ideas were too progressive
or too good for mainstream society of
needed to go the people whose ideas
and behaviour were unacceptable to the
rest of society have tended to go there.
So you know there's been some. Fantastic
ideas that have been born there.
There's been some wondering incredibles
that you wouldn't believe.
Pleasure.